make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so getting back in city of Bane Tom
Kings Batman this one deals almost
explicitly with Damian Wayne you guys
are gonna have to excuse me here I'm
actually very very very tired at the
moment I'm very very exhausted but uh
but yeah so the whole thing with city of
Bane up to this point those guys were
basically playing catch-up here the
whole idea behind this is that you've
essentially got Bane who managed to take
over Gotham City and he's kind of been
doing it in bits and pieces here and
there but it all really came to a head
when flashpoint Batman basically the
father of Bruce Wayne had defeated Bruce
Wayne himself and the result was that
with him basically being the new Batman
and Bruce Wayne temporarily being out of
the picture this basically leads to Bane
does kind of conquering everything and
so there was basically this ongoing rule
here the members of the bat family have
to stay out of Gotham City like all the
members of the bat family save for
Alfred who's being held by Bane and the
idea was that offered with a hostage the
notion was if you come into the city we
will kill Alfred and it's kind of a cool
thing because this is Damian Wayne
basically testing the waters and this is
why I always love the character of
Damian because a lot of ways Damian's
he's just kind of a kid right you know
doing what kids do but despite all of
that despite the fact that he is so like
hid he's also a very capable kid and so
he doesn't think about things in the
same way and so what you have is that in
the absence of Batman Damian Wayne kind
of takes on the shoulders to be like the
one person who will do whatever needs to
be done in order to essentially win the
day now the cool thing about this too is
that that Damian really seems to get
kind of ahead of himself and that's the
big shortcoming between or a big divin
between Damian and his father Bruce
Wayne is that Bruce Wayne of course when
he first started as Batman he was
reckless and all that kind of stuff and
it took a lot of mistakes it took some
errors it took things like the creation
of the Joker for him to learn patience
for him to learn that he needs to sort
of slow down that being Batman is more
of the long game it's as much a thinking
man's game as it is a physical game and
so as a result of that Damian Wayne
hasn't really had to play that role yet
I mean he has and so far as being an
assassin but being an assassin and being
Batman or not the same thing especially
when you're talking about a scenario
where a person is being held hostage
because the life of Damian is get in
there and kill don't necessarily worry
about anything else and so in this
instance he basically shows up with a
wand that belonged to cetana and then in
turn uses it in order to bind to Gotham
girl so it takes care of her pretty
quickly but the issue with this and this
is kind of the the big moment here is
that when all that goes down you
basically have this guy who's being
harassed by some
villains playing the role of cops and
then it turned Damien jumps in and this
is where the reckless nature of Damien
comes into play because under any normal
circumstance Batman probably would have
neutralized people like Gotham girl and
then anybody else who got in his way
pretty fast and removed them off the
board and at least done it in a way to
where nobody would suspect they were
gone or at least by the time they
suspected anything
Batman's already made his move and his
presence is already known presumably
Alfred would be saved and then in the
notion of of Damian it's get in there
and letting this kind of reckless part
like we have to save Gotham and defeat
the villains it's one of these things
where he hasn't quite learned the lesson
but sometimes you just kind of have to
let the small fish go so you could focus
on the big fish the problem with this
and really the reason why Danny enacted
in this instance is because this guy's
life was in jeopardy that because of the
nature of these villains because as
Victor Zsasz just loves to kill people
he would have taken this guy out he
would have shot his dog and he probably
would have shot the guy and so of course
it really kind of required Damian to act
this is why I say you know kind of
comparison to his to his father you know
honestly I don't think it's fall I don't
think Batman would have been as upfront
and straightforward about his appearance
right and if he had he'd have had a plan
set up instead Damian just kind of leaps
in so it's not really a question of all
these guys gonna be defeated they are
the question is what do they do next
right like what comes after this because
with Damian Wayne's presence being known
in in the city of Gotham
now flashpoint Batman appears and it's
kind of a cool little discussion that
goes on here because you have Damian who
basically says I know everything about
you right like you're my grandfather
from a different universe I really don't
know how you got here
your entire universe collapse because of
a button you're basically a failed
superhero Gotham is a travesty and then
the universe that you come from it's
kind of a cool little thing because this
is Damian again getting a little bit
haughty and get only getting a little
bit carried away with himself because
when that plays out of course the up
fight breaks out between himself and
flashpoint Batman and Damian initially
seems to get the upper hand on it and I
wouldn't even really say is flashpoint
Batman toying with him I mean one of the
things between this version of Batman
and and the actual Bruce himself as a
Bruce is a lot more nuanced in his
training he has a lot more finesse going
on there if I'm being honest with you
guys I don't really think the flashpoint
Batman would be able to defeat Damian in
hand-to-hand combat
but what Damian where Damian has in his
prodigious fighting style flashpoint
Batman or at least we can just kind of
call on Thomas I guess makes up for and
like his durability and size right
because he's a grown man he's with these
withstood his own flurry of punches and
issues and so on and so forth and and to
me it still doesn't quite work right
because I mean
of what use would Damien be if he
couldn't like take out grown men as an
assassin right I mean yeah at that point
you can't really claim that you're a
great assassin because your weakness is
basically like any adult anywhere ever
and so it's it's kind of interesting but
ultimately you know you know penny
Thomas who gives the upper hand on
Damien and seems to take him out pretty
quickly and so it's kind of interesting
here because when that happens Damian
Wayne is basically knocked out now what
I want to do here is I want to sidetrack
for a second it kind of this little side
sawed bit of a story going on that with
Bruce Wayne having been defeated by his
father previously ultimately he was
saved by Catwoman right so it was kind
of like this little background thing
going on where Catwoman was essentially
nursing him back to health now is this
kind of an interesting concept here
because we've seen things like this
before and most most notably we saw it
at the tail end of Scott Snyder's run on
Batman right the fact that Batman was
basically believed or at least Bruce was
believed to have been dead in his fight
with the Joker following the events of
in-game or I guess during the events of
in-game and then you end up having like
Commissioner Gordon hook who took over
it seems very similar to that but
insofar as a villain conquers Gotham
City and Batman's absence as opposed to
somebody else taking up the role of
Batman right I mean you saw the same
thing in nightfall you saw the same
thing during the return of Bruce Wayne
I mean we've kind of seen this happen
before where Bruce Wayne's incapacitated
and something else changes the
difference of the reason why I like this
so much is because it's a villain
conquering Gotham in the absence of
Bruce under any normal circumstance we
would expect it would be like Jean Paul
Valley who was the first one to do it or
Dick Grayson who is the second ru you
kind of expected that kind of situation
unfold but you don't really see it here
instead it's it's Bane conquering Gotham
City and that's why I dig this it's one
of the reasons why it's cool but
basically it's it's him working around
and kind of traveling around with
Catwoman but what she says is look like
your interview your recovery phase right
because I mean the indication seems to
be as soon as Bruce wakes up let's go to
Gotham we got to take everything like we
basically have to save the day there
doesn't really seem to be an indication
that he knows exactly what's going on
Selina Kyle's basically giving him the
rundown you know it's kind of explained
to him what's going on and so far is
what's happening he doesn't really know
the finer details because he's not there
he's not actually in Gotham City and
when Selina charms in and she says hey
look like just so you know if you do
this in your weakened state if you do
this you're going to die the city's
overrun by all the villains there's a
very very strong chance you're not gonna
want to call in any help from the bat
family because you're not gonna want to
put them in danger so you're gonna go in
as a one-man army trying to take on this
army of supervillains all of whom are
for bein either because they choose to
you or because soccer pirate manipulated
manipulated their emotions and is making
them do it you're gonna be fighting your
entire rogues gallery and then some
you're going to die if you do that and
the responsive Bruce Wayne is I know but
at least it'll be an honorable death now
this is what's interesting here because
the ongoing theory among the fan base
remember seeing Sal overcome a pop tweet
this out but the ongoing theory here is
that none of this is real none of this
is actually happening this is like a
dream or it's like the final nightmares
in the nightmare storyline I'm not 100%
sure but the indication is that none of
this is actually happening at all like
it's just some dream that he has or some
secrets of identities experiencing or
something along those lines I don't know
if it's like he's telling something to
call his worst nightmare of what what
could possibly happened like it we don't
really know what's going on it may all
actually be happening it may I'll
actually be true and happening in it's
all in real time and all this kind of
stuff but it seems very out of character
for Bruce Wayne to say yes I know I'll
die but it'll be an honorable death it
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
for Bruce to kind of adopt that
mentality it's always one of these
things of there has to be a way for me
to win right because of what you so mine
is a superhero if I don't win as it's
kind of a cool thing here because
ultimately Selina Kyle says fine if you
want to go and go in there go in there
but you're not going in alone like I am
going to go with you and that's just the
way it is there's no way you're going to
go by yourself and so it was a cool
little thing here because from here we
switch back over to Damian and this was
really the big moment right the moment
the like everybody's been talking about
in the college it's kind of like the big
thing that happens here because what
plays out is Damian basically wakes up
in this room right and he with any
disease essentially kind of being told
here's what's going on like you were
warned do not come here you were told
do not enter this city and you were told
that if you did that things were gonna
be bad that Alfred was going to die but
instead you chose not to listen like I
would love to do this in any other way I
would love to do whatever I needed to do
in order to make sure that you
understand what's going on though there
are consequences for the things that you
do that's one of the cool moments here
is because Damian Wayne despite his good
efforts has failed to understand one of
the most important things in this life
that we lived there are consequences for
the things that you say and do just
because there's a thing that you want to
achieve or the thing you want to do does
not mean that nothing will come of it
right that the only impact that'll
that'll come out of that is voting on
whatever impacts you that there are are
consequences that there are bigger
things that go on there and so it's kind
of crazy because when this happens
Damian Wayne cries out and Bane is
standing there with his hands over
it's head and bricks the neck of Alfred
Pennyworth and it's like wow like
literally Tom King just killed Alfred
I'm curious to see how people are gonna
take this right the people who are
already on the fence about it I don't
know if they're gonna like to support it
and be like dude this is awesome if
they're gonna be against it and be like
really people who hate it I don't know
if they're gonna hate it even more I
don't know if they're actually gonna
kind of turn and become bigger fans of
it I think it's a cool thing I think
it's kind of an interesting moment this
is why I say no this really seems to be
real right because DC doesn't really
mess around too much with the nature of
like death right like they kill a
character off and they usually kind of
stay dead I mean for the most like they
come back occasionally like sometimes
but DC is not nearly as you know
free-flowing with the the rules of death
as Marvel Comics is right like Marvel
comics will kill a person and bring them
back five issues later because it just
suits the story like DC doesn't really
do it all that often right like Hawk and
Dove you're like yeah I mean there's a
lot a lot of like a lot of concepts out
there like even with like the garden is
the universe and all those things being
destroyed it was one of those where like
the essence of what we are exists in the
Green Lantern the Green Lantern central
power battery recreate that and you'll
bring us back right it's the essence of
our life force that basically restores
us it's not like return from the dead or
something along those lines now assuming
this is true right like assuming that
that this is this is actually what
happened this is actually what went down
and this is all taking place in real
time like it's not a dream or anything
like that
then the only way to get out of this is
take out for pennyworth to the to the
Lazarus pits I mean that's that's the
most logical outcome but again it's it's
interesting I'm not really sure what
direction this is going it could go in
any number of ways but it's a huge
moment in the Batman mythos anyway right
in more recent years killing off Alfred
Pennyworth but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
and make sure you guys at the sub button
to become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]